c'est un règlement de compte par écran
interposé celui de simon castaldi
candidats de télé-réalité et d'hervé
patrons de bars à chicha enlevant des
jetons trois compères ton grand père
toute ta famille jetons
voilà qui compte
six mois
alors qu'il avait bouclé les
influenceurs pour une soirée samedi
dernier simon castaldi aurait empoché
l'argent sans jamais se présenter on se
donne rendez vous le samedi 27 novembre
dans votre bar le saint fulgent en
vendée à kouba qui aurait rendu fou
furieux hervé qui a demandé aux jeunes
garçons de le rembourser faute de quoi
il affichait son numéro sur les réseaux
sociaux je vais maintenant photo son
numéro de téléphone unique ce soir hervé
sur notre plateau pour régler ses
comptes
déjà merci hervé d'être là merci au
peuple dur avait quand même un
bon prix ce qui s'est passé mon va tout
simplement on a fait appel vous êtes un
restaurant qui s'appelle le qg c1 c'est
un bar bars à sushis chat d'accord le qg
voilà c'est ça très bien donc on a fait
appel au bon coeur si on tient sa ligne
pour en faire une soirée donc vous
vouliez simon castaldi pour une soirée
pour une prestation vous avez vous la
même prestation l'avait annoncé pour des
flyers et s'orne on a programmé cette
soirée donc au début le
le booker à simon qui voulait absolument
virement bancaire dont on possède pas
comme ça d'habitude on demande un
contrat qu'on signe d'accord donc on n'a
jamais une nouvelle et fait environ 450
euros je crois la voilà donc au début on
n'a jamais eu le contrat d'accord il
voulait absolument le virement bancaire
virement bancaire je savais pas qui
c'était cette personne donc j'ai fait
appel à un autre bon coeur qu'à
contacter ryad ixia électronique à une
autre candidate de télé d'accord qui est
qui et la copine à simon et
qui a donné mon numéro de téléphone à
simon et donc ses nombreux contacts et
me dit écoute tu t'occupes pas du booker
tu me fais directement le virement mois
d'accord ou pas de souci ça se passe
bien avec simon jusqu'à se montrent pas
de souci donc il était pressé pressé
d'avoir le virement donc je lui fais
à partir du moment où les virements plus
nouvelle d'accord qu'une nouvelle sam
une semaine il a fallu que j'appelle
j'appelle j'appelle à chaque fois je
ferai pas je suis débordé je regarde les
snap d'addiction il en pls dans son
canapé en train de ronfler
ok bon pas de souci puisque la bon on
dit rien et puis
et puis bon bah ça continue donc je fais
appel aux booker juridique si elle
connaît dans un dictionnaire s'occupe de
voir avec simon pour qu'il me fasse à
vider au bout d'une semaine
une fée la vidéo bon on lance la pub
puisque là pas de souci je lui ai dit
écoute je te rappelle pour qu'on voie
pour les vhr je l'appelle il répond pas
j'ai envoyé un message il répond pas
puisque la bon ben on aura dit je
l'appelle juba comment on fait ce que là
on est vendredi non on a comment on fait
j'ai même pas ton nom ton prénom je sais
même pas d'où tu viens et puis moi il
m'a été vendus il m'a été vendu à la
base avec un vieil cher un vhr
c'est quoi le premier français mais
enfin
la chaîne et donc qui me dit de toute
façon je viens pas seul donc il m'a
répondu devant randy mais dis moi je dit
écoute juste envoyer des messages tu
réponds pas
j arrive à un moment et je dois écoute
moi c'est vrai que mon équipe de sécu on
a cinq sujets en vendée et c'est la
campagne avec des campagnards il n'y a
pas deux lascars c'est que des gentils
moi je suis sponsors que deux clubs de
sport il ya que des footeux des
basketteurs que des gens très courtois
que de bonne famille bon je comprends
pas je lui ai dit écoute moi là car vhr
c'est à toi de voir moi j'ai pas autant
d'agents de sécu c'est l'habitude de
m'occuper de tous les gens qui viennent
en vendée on n'a pas de soucis une
nouvelle aurait il pas mieux la soirée
non m'aider à partir du vendredi
plus de réponses
plus de réponses ok nous on a tout
acheté un nom s'est classé plus on a
fait la bouffe on en avait pris les
réservations on a tout fait samedi pas
de nouvelles et on l'appelle on
l'appelle j'ai envoyé tous les messages
j'ai scanné tous les messages j'ai fait
tout j'ai tout fait ok on sentait la
carotte les gens nous appellent en
lisant basse simon vient de faire une
vidéo il part examen 6h10 y
en a tant car vous avez fait une vidéo
ensuite pour vous plaindre ouais c'est
dans la section s'énerve et du
comportement de simon parce qu'il ya des
gens qui sont venus qu'ont réservé que
pour sont venus exprès pour voir si mon
temps car celle ci je sais pas si vous
vous rendez compte mais là on n'est pas
en ville on est en campagne donc les
gens et les gens sont venus exprès pour
voir si vous vous en ont voulu les gens
vous on dirait alors pas moi puisque
nous on est là on a fait les choses en
sorte de payer idée c'est de payer un
coup aux gens pour voilà leur dire voilà
mais il y en a qui a eu lieu la con
quand même payer leur lors leur bouffe
tout ça bon on s'est excusé
bon c'est vrai que moi ça m'agace et ça
m'agace et la télé et c'est surtout ne
pas avoir de réflexes quoi vous n'avez
pas eu de réponse depuis à 6 ah ba si
bob a forcément vu la vidéo que je lui
ai fait en donnant son numéro de
téléphone puisqu'il répondait pas donc
ça pas d'importance donc j'ai fait une
vidéo et puis
pas plus que on nous prend pour des
combats jumet son numéro de téléphone en
direct et je peux vous dire que l' arrêt
on a simple jean en accentuent gens en
vendait à l'ats par contre à la il n'a
eu que des messages toute la lumière
très commercial truc commercial mais bon
si je que son manager à 3 heures du
matin qui m'a dit tu vas voir ma chambre
s'en fout alors vous avez fait on va
regarder la vidéo vous avez fait le live
d'hervé où vous êtes énervé contre simon
tu sais très bien ce que tu as fait
ton est assez dommage déposerait pas le
contrepoint qu'un mec est malhonnête
je ne faisais mes jetons toi ton père
ton grand père tu de ta famille tu en
voilà et puis t'es qu'un escroc été
qu'un escroc jette affichée par tous
alba donkey kong ton père du taureau
encore si vos cas samedi
[Musique]
bon alors c'est
non c'est cela bien alors je vous dire
une chose moi je me suis renseigné je
sais pas quel est le début le
commencement est sûr d'une autre billet
train ils en voulaient de il en voulait
et c'est ce que vous avez fait là
d'abord s'appelle insulter des gens plus
publiquement moi et mon père traiter sa
mère depuis tout ça ça je vous dis
franchement ça ne se fait pas monsieur
je ne sais pas après les relances les
messages que j'ai sur mon téléphone vous
le menacer c'est quoi ces façons de
faire vous créez vous aussi vous voyez
68 ray 3d sort de
ces points je suis m'insulter mais toi
tu redescends je m'en fout de toi déjà
pour commencer et déjà je vais vous dire
arrêter ici c'est aujourd'hui votre fils
il fait les martiens duras et grâce à
qui c'est quand son public c'est pas
grave ça mais qu'est-ce que quand les
gens quoi vous mettez dans la sauce
encore mais deux importants mais des
modes à la sauce je voudrais parler de
mon père de sa mère etc et c'est quoi le
rapport il faut qu'on trouve le moyen
pour le pour et le moyen de vendre a vu
que la reine moyen de quoi c'est nous
donc on a su que les gens en public
reprend les réseaux à témoin sont deux
au téléphone c'est quoi ces façons de
faire la fête mais qu'est ce que tu
racontes mais
c'est vrai on appelle comme les bonnes
manières les quiz sur la wii c'est moi
qui va brûler gravats veux qu'on nous
avait parlé hier à l'orée du mal
à personne bassam assurément les
versions vous dire je ne sais pas quel
élan brouille l'a certainement une ce
que vous avez fait sur les réseaux
données sont elles sont nulles au
téléphone portable insulté sa mère mon
père et moi je n'y suis pour rien
monsieur on se connaît non je vous ai
escroqué non je vous ai manqué de
respect non on pourrait vous le faites
c'était pourquoi vous faites taponnat ma
question pourquoi vous le faites c'est
pourquoi j'ai appelé mon avocat parce
que y'en a marre maintenant le 2 on en
attend à l'esprit c'est bien fini et
moquée par espèce que moi bon alors on a
en face aux quais bas donc tu va
redescendre au second si j'y aille la
loi maintenant on va arrêter de se faire
chier dessus sur les réseaux comme ça
parce que les mecs pète un plomb pour
moi j'avais geoffrey chez moi nous
entrons séraphine et ils ont qu'à faire
je ne suis pas d'être copieux mais je
reste je ne suis pas mon fils je ne suis
pas dans cette histoire donc vous
insulter mon père sa mère et moi ça
s'appelle savent assumer donc ça se fait
porter plainte ensuite vous le menacer
et vous me menacer donc je vais reporter
peur parce qu'il est maintenant vous
allez arrêter de poids de penser cadeaux
sociaux mais c'est un des maires soir à
merde et qu'on peut tout dire les pics
verts toulousains vers la loi monsieur
votre fille jouait l'armée serbe je suis
pas mon fils et fils qui joue à la
gueule à ses camarades fils qui m'a fort
djediat tuquoi la liane là je m'en fou
qu'est ce que tu racontes gars m'en fou
qu'est ce que tu racontes là c'est alors
arrête de nous faire chier et ont fait
insulter les camarades qu'elle coûtait
alors j'écoute pas je ne suis pas prêt d
soit ni mon père ni moi ni sa mère
attention tu ne manques pas du pays ni à
moi ni à tromper la vie à sa mère sa
compris c'est tout donc la loi et loi je
porte plainte c'est pas pour moi c'est
le public menace et faut arrêter penser
que les réseaux sociaux un déversoir
amer peux vous dire en taisant je m'en
fous je n'ai
pas d'excusé mais les débats n'ont
maintenant je m'excuse va pas très bien
très bien je porterai plainte huppert à
l'examen super va pas avec nous sont
élevées à dire commence à me faire chier
alors déjà moi je voudrais un tout petit
est tout simple moi j'ai des enfants et
je sais que quand il ya un problème on
écoute les deux versions là c'est ça
marion et dentaire et vga tandis que
j'ai bien accroché j'aurais fini je ne
sais pas que je ne suis pas dans
l'assaut je suis donc manqué par respect
ni un mois et demi à mon père et à sa
mère fin de l'histoire voilà l'effet des
histoires avec mon fils pas avec moi et
paito avec sa mère ses pairs ouais et tu
tes excuses auprès de moi et de mon père
et de sa mère et après on discute pas le
faire non et bah très bien le superbe
monsieur platret moi je veux c'est super
hervé ses traditions et ses défauts
aussi voilà c'est dit voilà donc on
essaie de trouver les meilleures
solutions en plus moi j'ai rien c'est
vrai qu'il a rien à voir un thon germon
je suis d'accord avec vous non mais
c'est encore encore et vous je suis de
la revue non mais tu connais fait un
coup de pub pour ton petit varois c'est
normal non mais on s'en fout du petit
bar c'est pas la question du petit bar
cc même pas la question de l'argent
savait pas si sa part barça pour les uns
en jeu donc je crois et je pense que
l'argent il me semble il sombre dans la
rendu à samedi après midi qu'une fois
que le feu est ce qu'il l'a rendu cet
après midi et ce qui l'a rendu cet après
midi et ce qui l'a rendu oui ou non cet
après midi ok donc je me suis fait chier
dessus j'ai rien fait mon père est celle
ci dessus il arrêtait sa mère on traite
de [ __ ] c'est pas grave l'histoire est
réglé et on se fait de la pub on vient à
l'île des masses et sa mère m'a insulté
sur ce plateau et c'est ça se comporter
en gentleman été signalé en être humain
sans les pavillonneurs son fils q mon
plus beau fils il est majeur je n'ai
rien à voir avec ça mais je suis ni moi
ni mon père ni sa mère du jeu voilà
aujourd'hui je vais en face d'eux en
face de moi c'est tout a laissé moi
laissez moi finir beaucoup sur vous
m'excuser pour mon père ma mère et moi
maintenant où ça ira plus loin voilà
parce que je voulais à compose de
t'énerver mais faut arrêter d'insulter
les gens gratuitement on lutte contre sa
ya un problème on s'explique 02/03
garage à regarder monsieur hervé lui
avoir eu la magie suis pour rien mon
pote c'est moi finir j'aurais bien voulu
aussi avoir et ce que j'y suis pour
quelque chose je peux monsieur mon père
y est est-ce que ça mais rien de sûr
peut-être plus de compris oui ben thabet
faudrait écouter écoute bien alors
j'écoute bien écoute bien que bien dû
amerrir à ce que je peux finir récemment
fait une rue de correction de nous
appeler et de répondre ça on se bat pas
on serait jamais arrivé lundi régler ça
entre vous pas sur les réseaux en
mettant tout le monde dans la sauce
arrêté pour penser que les réseaux c'est
un déversoir pour les uns contre c'est
quoi cette façon de penser qui s'incline
kg mais c'est quoi ces façons de penser
à arrêter avec ça fait des problèmes ça
fait des menaces ça fait des gens
malheureux ça fait dur mis en garde à
vue ça fait des drames ça ça c'est les
gens à se venger vous voulez quoi que
les gens se bouffe tous les uns les
autres se fera plus sec ou louer
[Applaudissements]
insulter les gens c'est ça mais c'est ça
et après on s'étonne que ma joie extrême
cette année c'est vous et vous êtes
irresponsables à cause de gens comme
vous on se frappe sans la gueule pour
rien bah c'est vrai que vous méritez
même pas d'essence plateau fils et vous
êtes indigne d'être là bas il sait
parler je m'en fous je vous le dis moi
ça va je m'engage à rabat en l'air
on peut comprendre qu'hervé non je crois
qu'il était déçu et irrité console est
venu court terme et il était déçu de la
hutte très bien faire déçu sage il a
dépensé beaucoup c'est votre fils cap
lkp le dimanche en menaçant c'est pas
j'en sais rien et s'en servent ainsi
l'affairé jean claude et moi je suis
dans la sauce vous mettez une famille
dans la sauce mais
on sait très bien qu elle correcte bon
alors est ce qu'on peut trouver une
solution maintenant vous l'a dit
de lui depuis dix ans nous alors on s'en
contre un car de l'été au regard de
l'histoire n'a pas eu d'atteinte de lui
devoir en niveau on essaie de trouver
une solution à cette affaire s'il vous
plaît la lâchant julien courbet là ce
soir
j'ai pas je m'en fous de cette histoire
je ne suis pour rien moi je vais juste
plus je veux qu'on arrête moi j'arrivais
de régler ses comptes
les revélois virement il a su soit son
pognon c'est une coupe mais aussi que je
vais dire si c'est effectivement mon
fils s'est mal comporté voilà je suis
désolé min ça ne mérite pas votre
comportement je vous crois autant que
lui je ne sais pas c'est votre parole
contre la sienne donc on gérait les deux
versions moi ce que je veux plus
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui vous avait fait
c'est de des déjeuners à n voilà ça je
veux plus ça c'est pas fait pour valable
pour vous et pour tout le monde
d'ailleurs quoi là j'aurais été content
mais je vous entends croyez moi je n'y
suis pour rien monsieur mais chez moi je
veux pas avoir je peux avoir des alertes
google les mes potes qui habite qu'est
ce qui s'est passé ton fils avoir des
messages d'insultés moi sur mon
téléphone en disant des alliés monsieur
et des résolutions à une femme moi j'ai
moi j'ai que j'ai quatre enfants j'ai
pour mes besoins de monsieur dans les
bottes pour autant de boîtes de nuit
dont se branler vote fils à la map les
dimanches mais je m'en fous moi je ne
veux pas qu'on soit je veux pas que vous
fassiez ça vous inciter à la haine
expliqué le à votre fils alors mais
c'est lui qui avait laissé ses pétales
et beau que jamais la vidéo c'est bon
arrêtez avec la vision en france que
c'est bon il m'a accusé
vidéo quand et je voudrais ville de pau
en direct mais nous devons aborder et
poule c où p j'aimerais que tout le
monde soit content ah bah ouais pas
content du doubs et
servez hervé hervé mois moi j'aimerais
que tout monde soit content ce soit donc
j'ai peut-être un truc à vous proposer
benjamin castaldi à venir aux
bouquinistes la nation là mais j'ai
peut-être quelque chose à
présent je vais en vendée et un âne avec
yoplait souple et de nom mais vous allez
alors hervé novelli un truc à vous
proposer parce que voilà benjamin
castaldi et là vous êtes là ce soir il
ya julien même qui veut réagir un de vos
fils non c'est pas la bonne qui est très
nerveux usba album oui on se bloque
alors il parait qu'il veut raffiner
alors mettez vous doutez pas mais je
viens dans la sauce ou alors c'est bon
c'est bien d'affirmer c'est bon j'ai
alors à côté lyonnais
benjamin aujourd'hui tu es dans quelle
disposition par rapport à mon amant des
revenus
de bois
m'a jamais je me redresse position gérer
aucune disposition envers ce monsieur je
me retrouve avec des menaces non mon
fils et menacé sa fiancée menacé tout le
monde est menacé il a voulu faire un
coup de buzz qui a des conséquences qui
sont extrêmement regrettable et qui sont
extrêmement dommageable et que je trouve
dramatique pour histoire de boîte de
nuit alors certainement qu'il ya une
main concurrence terrain mais au final
mais les conséquences est ce que dans la
série des metal deux minutes sait on en
parle tout le temps ici c'est dès que
des conséquences qui sont dramatiques
c'est à dire que j'ai eu mon grand fils
julien khimki mal qui menace et voilà
j'ai mon fils qui est menacée ils
avaient forcé le mauvais ce qui menace
et j'ai la mère de de julien et de simon
qui auront tous les états parce qu'elle
trouve ça épouvantable et qu'elle
comprend ce qui se passe et que les
conséquences sont ces 6 6e ça aurait pu
être très très simple et c'est de ça
devient une affaire d'état effectivement
et avec des conséquences que je trouve
de plus en plus regrettable et en parle
toujours dans cette émission les gens
font des choses impulsif moi je peux
comprendre qu'il était énervé est vide
je dis je le comprends très bien mais
faut maintenant les gens comprennent que
quand on fait des choses ça a des
conséquences qui maintenant je trouve
sont dramatiques qui ont des vraies
conséquences dans la vie de tous les
jours et je suis maintenant il faut
lutter contre ça on peut on a droit
d'être d'être en colère on avoue ne pas
être d'accord on a peut-être d'avoir un
sentiment que c'est mais on n'a pas le
droit on n'a pas le droit de faire en
sorte que la haine se déchaîne sur les
autres et parce que monsieur ça a des
conséquences et un jour je vous le dis
faites pas fait ça s'il vous plaît mais
un jour quand il y aura un drame quand
on aura quelqu'un qui qui serait acquis
qui sera frappé ou qui sera but et on
viendra sur le plateau pour pleurer
parce qu'ils étaient buté et ce sera
trop tard monsieur monsieur ce sera trop
tard salle bayard eu un drame ce sera
trop tard je n'ai plus rien à vous dire
je vous souhaite bon courage d'aller
voir avec cela dit je vous le souhaite
le voir c'est vrai fils mais moitié à
l'initiative oui très bien que c'est le
bâtiment financé lui benjamin lagarde et
jean simon prix cette année et peut-être
qu'il a peut-être qu'il a eu tort mais
si mon fils ne faut pas mal taillé pour
un coup de barre à mine et que je le
retrouve mort dans la rue parce que vous
avez déclenché la haine chez moi
d'ailleurs bovary c'est moi les voiles
et voilà c'est moi qui avais droit et
lorient n'a pas monsieur c'est moi je
suis mort n'est pas content ce que vous
faites c'est vrai vous n'êtes jamais
vous ne vous rendez pas compte si vous
ne faites vibrer vd ge est inconséquent
mieux mais c'est le n'ai plus rien à
vous dire mais moi aussi je verrai pas
la seule la vie des gens vont pas de la
sandale la vie les gens aux pédiatres
s'emballe monsieur lavis région paca 200
balles lys à l'office
mais je m'en fous je suis puisqu'il est
majeur moi je suis pour car vous le
défendez j'ai juste défendu jusqu'à ce
dont j'étais j'ai pas dis y'a surement
arts erts vient sûrement un problème
latent prendre inverser les rôles c'est
oui c'est moins bien dans les rucks et
moi si les chaînes line sur les oiseaux
c'est vous monsieur c'est vous qui
balancent telesur a diffusé en disant
vous ne nous aidez réponse à maintenant
mais il n'ya pas que sur les réseaux qui
l'a pas fait sur les réseaux écoulé sur
les réseaux ou t écoute alors arrêté au
début qu'on est là pour faire un coup de
buzz un coup de pub heureusement qu'en
mission accomplie bravo monsieur leur
chapeau doit ouais voilà pour moi merci
voilà voilà voilà
chapeau bas sam ard souplesse au calme
et de la rbs comprenez que la gamme 1 et
1 et un talent liste de oui mais non ou
même nom je vais pas lui dire où il s'en
passe en moyenne sur savez moi je vais
vous dire un truc à partir du moment qui
est un problème on écoute la partie on
regarde on regarde vraiment ce qu'il ya
eu pas de souci moi je sais que j'ai les
insulter mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé
avant c'est simon qui m'appelle dimanche
en disant je vais venir te nique et
tatati nains assez normal que le mec je
voulu répondre au téléphone vous croyez
qu'on va se faire par un gamin de 20 ans
voilà bah écoutez la réaction était
était plus voilà que vous le souhaitez
mais c'était comme ça je proportionnelle
est passé c'est votre fils capelle alors
est ce qu'on peut trouver des solutions
pour que tout le monde soit content
hervé est ce que vous pouvez refaire une
autre soirée j'ai quelqu'un vous
proposer
câble a fait comme l'a fait il aime la
fête ils aiment ils aiment s'habiller il
m il aime se dévêtir également
de l'ensemble dans ses peintures non
c'est moi moi ce que je propose c'est
que heu tu sais que mokhtar veut y aller
d un motard venir aucune mais c'est vrai
venir filmer du raffut multi choix voilà
qui est prêt à donner un petit coup de
main à hervé voilà pour y aller un soir
guillaume avec plaisir bien sûr mais par
contre j'ai quelques conditions c'est
quoi j'aimerais que l'impression d'un
flyer qui met bien en valeur cette
chemise c'est ma chemise préférée à toi
tout péter je crois et quelques paquets
de chips gratuit égal
et bien sûr et plaisir pour voilà
[Applaudissements]
ça va être la folie sentent aujourd'hui
c'est quelqu'un d'intègre aussi c'est
vrai que kelly qui vient de jard-sur-mer
elle est pas très loin alors qu'elle y
est ce que voulait y aller aussi mr oui
bah vous allez y retourner mais mais
vous pouvez comprendre à quel point
benjamin cesser mon tonton et je peux
pas lui faire il aurait aussi benjamin
c'est benjamin benjamin je sais que tu
es obligé l'autorisation à un amour de
mais je sais que tu comprends aussi
hervé est un petit peu triste que tu es
petit tu rigoles comme ça de données
étaient tout est ce que tu en voilà tu
comprends aussi que lui aussi il arrive
est mort hier et orbi que son business
continue que voilà c'est ça revient je
vais pas lui file un coup de main ça
c'est sûr mais maintenant si maintenant
si des gens veulent y aller c'est
pourquoi je ne vois pas où est ce qu'on
vous pouvez juste vous excuser juste
pour sa part son ami est bon pour mon
père pour ça mais là bas très bien voilà
voilà bravo
regardez on va faire une bonne affaire
le bisou
il
ya le covidien variable mais
qu'on peut rien vous dire je bois je
voulais très besoin et qui s'excuse il
l'a fait voilà bien différencier il ya
eu un lien différent très bien mais
voilà mes pensées il va nous plonger
dans ses pas bien indivis apprendre pas
mal non là c'est pour le fait pour hervé
l'a fait pour garder parce que je tiens
à dire que tous les deux tiens à dire
que sera de mathieu essayer de récupérer
le marché pendant la pub maintenant je
fais 50 % moins cher non hervé on y va
tous les deux tous les deux alors à lui
c'est très cher
je ferais gratuitement pour essayer dé
jalousie on en est si je le ferai mais
je vais venir avec guillaume genton je
ne rigole pas voilà je viendrai tu nous
dis voilà on va trouver une date dans
deux ou trois semaines la situation mais
c'est bon avant noël avant noël ok
babandoa l'on viendra mediouri jacuzzi
mais ça n'en a pas besoin de ça on est
bien avec caribbean the radio j'entends
avant noël et on croit une soirée et
c'est bien sûr on fait ça gratuitement
ça va je rigole pas été pas trop déçu
qu'on arrive parce que jamais douté pas
comment on fait non plus mais bon c'est
bon des deux côtés je pense que bon on
avait un peu voilà les esprits se sont
un peu échauffés mais bon après c'est
comme ça donc est heureux ce soir
alors simon castany je sais que ses
énormes regrets après la mecque
et je fais les genres on est très
contents si jamais ça ne fait jamais
sans ses scieries vient pas chez reed
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
aller à la guerre des mots j'aimerais
vraiment vous réconcilier tous les deux
parce que c'est vrai c'est mon nom est
pas non plus me tue à savoir l on sait
bons rails ça va c'est bon je suis
angoissé ville très bien super parce
qu'en plus ce qu il était la mémoire
sont bien moins annoncés n'ont pas dit
non non non quelqu'un allez on passe à
autre chose